[Music]
language does does matter you know with
with transgender people people joke a
lot they're like oh they wanna they want
to be called them yeah yeah yeah he and
she is made up to he's stupid bitch you
know I mean but the thing is his words
have power words have power if you don't
believe it
date someone who calls you dummy you
know they mean who's there sounds from a
mammal no they're not they're spells
we're putting we're casting spells on
each other I do this on stage as a
stand-up sometimes I go I point to
someone in the front row I go that's a
great shirt that's you made a great
choice of that shirt and you can see
even though they know I'm just kind of
joking around or making a point it works
why do why do we say have a great
weekend that's just a spell you're just
going like I have no control over your
weekend but words matter they change our
interior world have a great weekend yeah
it's not literal I'm not like I'm
thinking about your weekend you get laid
text me the word finance that's how
that's all no you had a good weekend so
I think words do matter I think because
I'm into I like unit of consciousness
which is not that trippy of an idea
science agrees the big the theory of the
Big Bang is obviously the singularity at
one point all of this was one thing it
was this impossibly dense speck of mass
basically that contain everything
contain this lighting thing and the
camera and me and my hair and my balls
it was all in there the mystic you know
me I just think that that singularity is
worthy of a metaphor that's worthy of a
story or a symbol system so that I
cannot just know it but feel it and
experience it right both the mystic and
the scientists agree both are just
theories that everything at one point
was one so when it comes to like being
called a pronoun I'm like sometimes I
like to call other people me I go like
oh these me is voted for Trump this may
is begging for change this me is driving
me to the airport
I find that useful in
said of going like because it's so
pleasant to go like you I think it's
overwhelming to love I don't think hate
is actually hate I think it's too
overwhelming to love so we call groups
like it's hard to pick an example
because they all sound it so hateful but
if somebody like hates left-handed
people right I think it's because it can
be too overwhelming to love that group
that you call left-handed people because
if you love them now you have to worry
about them and you have to care about
them so we get overwhelmed in our heads
so we go oh a group died but they were
gang members okay gang members up here I
don't love them they can die so this is
what we do so it's helpful sometimes in
our language to go like no those Me's
are in a gang you know what I mean
that's that's a way that language can
it's very trippy and I don't like sign
on and start doing that but I do it
privately
especially if anybody's serving you or
helping you or or you think you're like
oh this is the flight attendant know
this me just brought me a sprite thank
you
I'm he's doing great looks looks nice
it's just a nice way to kind of increase
compassion instead of going this flight
attendant look that's that's a label we
made so we feel okay about yelling at
them that there should be more overhead
space now that me is doing my best
[Music]
but out I don't know how I got on them
who cares I don't know if you're gonna
get it take some mushrooms and watch
this video again